as russian rescuers are getting down to
well what they have been flown in here
for
i want you to just look around and let
something sink in
about the sheer and ultimate demolition
power behind this explosion we are in
the very epicenter as close as a
civilian can get
look closely under my feet i do
apologize for my
dirty sneakers but look closely because
i'm not stepping
on dirt or sand or anything this is
actually corn
seeds of corn from this massive towering
reservoir which is no more because of
the blast
and this is the very first site where
russian rescuers are
searching for survivors
[Music]
they're telling me that they are ready
to work overnight if there's any
possibility of finding
somebody alive
this is a field hospital in its early
stages it is
just being built in fact there's another
group of emergency workers
on the way with more infrastructure but
this
is where russian rescuers will be taking
those injured
those still in need of medical attention
from after the blast
[Music]
i'm very extremely lucky to be alive
actually
because i ca i can't i can't forget the
explosion the sound
the the visuals in front of my eyes wow
and i literally saw body parts of people
thrown in the main road people screaming
kids screaming body parts i saw a hand i
saw two legs
i went towards people and told them we
should not be here at that moment
i turned around and i was hit by
something in my right hand
that's when the big explosion started it
threw me to the ground
well everything that you can see around
me
was erected overnight it was literally
an empty
lot well fast forward six odd hours and
well there's already a small tent city
[Music]
here
well these search dogs have been
traveling with me
or rather i was with them and they
will be sniffing out those who may be
still trapped
and alive under the rubble the city of
beirut is devastated
morally physically financially in fact
of all places that i've ever been to
apart from active war zones of course
this one with all the
rubble destruction and vehicles just
abandoned at the side of the road
resembles a scene from a
post-apocalyptic movie the most
and the russian aid effort aims here at
relieving
at least some of the pain amigos dana
reporting from beirut in lebanon
rt
you